I told you in the last video on calendar
notation that regardless of whether
you're using BC ad or BCE and CE e that
there is no year 0 that we had one BC
and then we had that theoretical birth
of Jesus and most historians don't think
that he was born right exactly on
January 1 184 3 first 1 BC to January
1st 180 there's no year 0 and despite
the fact that I emphasize that in the
last video I didn't take that into
consideration when I calculated how many
years there were between Plato's birth
and Columbus discovering the new world
and the reason why I didn't take that in
consideration is that the Year 1492
whether you want to call it ad 1492 anno
domini 1492 whether you want to call it
that or whether you want to call it 1492
in the Common Era it's not 1492 years
since the theoretical birth of Jesus
which we know is not the actual birth he
was probably born before that it is 1491
years since the birth of Jesus and to
think about it this way let's just
assume like I'll keep them something
it's a theoretical date that we're
talking about this theoretical event
this kind of birth of Jesus that our
calendars revolve around if we if we
talk about January 1 let's think about
it this way so January January 1 1 in
the Common Era in the Common Era how
long is that since the birth of Jesus
it's not one year you wouldn't just look
at this it's been one year because this
is theoretically the the day that he was
born so this is 0 years or almost 0
years since that theoretical birth of
Jesus another way to think about it is
how long after January 1 January 1 the
year 1 before the Common Era and I could
have called this ad and I could have
called this BC what's the time
difference but
wean these two dates so the way I
calculated before I said oh this is one
year after that theoretical birth that's
wrong
this is during that theoretical birth
but if I did the way I did in the last
video said oh that's one year after one
year before you add them together and
you would get two but that's wrong
because there is no year 0 so January 1
181 in the common error is right over
here and then January 1 1 BCE is exactly
one year before that so there's only one
year one year difference and the reason
why the math is strange is because there
is no year 0 if there was a year 0 then
my calculation in the last video was
correct so really the way that you would
calculate the time between Plato's birth
at 428 BC and Columbus sailing across
the Atlantic in 1492 you would say okay
this is this is 428 years before that
theoretical birth of Christ but this
isn't 1492 years after that theoretical
birth this is 1492 minus one so what you
would do is you would add these two
numbers this is 428 before this is 1492
minus 1 years after so you would add
them and then subtract 1 so the correct
answer so this is the correction part
it isn't 1920 years between Plato's
birth and Columbus it is we want to
subtract one from that it is 1920 minus
one years so that is 1919 years the same
way that the difference between one ad
and one BCE you would say up you can
almost view it as like you know positive
and negative numbers you say oh this is
positive 1 minus negative 1 that would
give me 2 but there is no 0 so you
subtract another 1 so this is exactly 1
year difference so that's just want to
clarify that that's what that no year 0
does to us